because potheads are you know the they
are pretty lazy I'll admit it and I'm
not not like every other pothead so I
call it out when I see it especially
when I'm at a place of work where I'm in
charge of people and supervising
it's hard to be the nice guy and you
know
be the bad guy at the same time
when you say potheads are lazy what do
you mean uh you know sometimes there's
the idea people say potheads they smoke
weed they get high they don't do
anything but you know there's potheads
that like to get stuff done and there's
lots of different types of potheads I
think there's also depends how you smoke
too what you're smoking and the type of
weed you're smoking matter of fact back
in the day like when I was younger there
was sativa indica and there was you
smoked sativa to get energy you smoke
Indica to you know feel better to numb
her and go to sleep it's not that way
anymore it's actually weird because
they've actually crossed so many strains
of weed over the years doing stuff
genetically that there's weed from Asia
that grows actually in veggies in the
dark and in the cold which is you know
opposite of hours but they figure hey
let's breed them together and let's
create a super weed and you know
through the genetics and stuff there's
weed now like I said sativas that make
you more slower and Stony like an indica
and vice versa Indica is to give you
more energy and more you know
flow of feeling and just versus you know
what the older thought used to be where
it was the opposite so you can't really
judge it anymore like that wheat is so
much changed and the industry you know
when when we became legal I I was very
happy thinking like everybody else like
okay cool this is the next step for
legalization for you know bettering our
you know whatever's going on the United
States because the drug war is really
bad and it you know going into the the
working there I've got my way up to
where I started you know trimming you
know de-leafing we have people who just
like in industry in the cultivations
where they're massive they have maybe
four in each building four Grow rooms
four flower rooms four bedrooms trim
rooms
um distribution rooms and these are all
isolated in different buildings and
where I work in Adelanto it's called the
Greenbelt and in Adelanto California
they call it the Greenbelt because
that's an area where the the voltage of
the you know the where areas you can
have buildings brick and mortar
buildings is so high up because there's
a jail out there there's the ice
Attention Center there's all these
things that are so watched and regulated
right there that let's put pop you know
cultivation dispensaries there and
that's what they did and they're where I
work there's an area it's a big lot
where they got like 10 different units
and they're still building more down the
road they're literally vastly going out
into the desert and just popping up
these huge buildings and they're all
cultivations
um some around really good like you know
I don't work for some of them and I've
seen inside they will run really
efficiently really well
um but some do not do not run very well
I've worked in legit ones where I had to
you know do everything paperwork as if
I'm employed there which you know legit
and I've worked uh also on under the
table at ones where it was really shady
to the point where I'm thinking man this
is not right this is kind of like even
like you know the people working there
there's this animosity to kind of look
at each other like you know we're
getting the job done but you know hey
you do that I do that you know it's your
fault if that doesn't work it's it the
people would imagine the wheat
Industries you know peaches and cream
because it's you know probably getting
hot which we do we get high you know
smoke drink beers on our lunch break and
stuff and just party everyone's got like
so many different drugs cocaine is like
easy I mean it's funny how the weed game
in California and anywhere in general
you can get like rosin wax rosin that's
like 150 200 a gram I mean you're
talking price of cocaine there so that
this industry now is credits where you
have people who like to party or do
things on the site and the money they
can spend on weed good weed is the
amount of money you're going to be
spending on harder drugs and that's part
of the reason that I'm thinking that
like the whole industry of legalization
is not legit anyway you go to a
dispensary for example and you go pick
up see what you've got top shelf the
stuff they have there may not be the
best stuff that they have a lot of
places what they do is they'll be
growing weed and they'll they'll
literally put the stuff they want to
just sell obviously up front first get
rid of that and the stuff that's really
great and we're not seeing the regular
people aren't seeing and you know I'm
I'm always the underdog kind of guy so
even though I work there and I'm behind
the scenes I think like hey man like you
know that's still not cool like I could
tell my buddy hey I worked there but you
know you have to get it this way or do
that or buy it through me this way
and uh you know in the in the industry
I've done a lot of things I've done to
where like I said picking the leaves
doing basic stuff which is you know easy
work to where I've actually gone to the
rooms where I'm hanging the plants on
netting we have rooms full of just Nets
everywhere and you have 1400 plants or
so roughly hanging sometimes less
because some of the plants will be like
[__] plants are just small they're not
you know producing so we'll cut them out
get rid of them we don't waste that
space and um you know as you're working
you're doing this this is the industry
where you know Swede work in swed yeah
this is great but you know there's lots
of things that people don't realize that
are just like kind of like just
not cool working there like during covet
for example how to wear a mask
so you're in a room by yourself or with
another person you have to wear a mask
for whatever reason because they're
they're demanding that because you know
that's their industry their cultivation
and I'm I'm pulling plants down and
literally like people don't know this
because you know by time you handle weed
it's been processed through so many
different hands different bags and stuff
the static electricity the bag can like
take off like like small minute little
like trichomes and like crystals that
you wouldn't even see but they like fall
over my face by the end of the day I'm
like coated it looks like I'm just like
glazed like a Krispy Kreme donut and my
eyes are just like not wanting to close
like if you do that job and you actually
rub your eye oh man I've done that you
got a bloody eye like looking like you
just like got tattooed on your eye or
something because you got all these
minute little like needles caked into
your eyeball and of course equal or PPE
you know they wear that stuff but it's
the weed industry we're all high you
know we're trying to get the job done
and they don't really care to protect
people the way they should so it's me
being like the supervisory we're all
trying to make sure that I'm keeping
myself safe and everybody else
but the thing is too is like they don't
even employ like like people like you
and me really like people like me will
be there to like be the eyes or the okay
for the company but what they'll do is
they'll employ contractors from like
Mexico
and they do that because it's cheaper
they've done that you know throughout
time in California through the you know
farming industry and stuff they've
always taken contractors from Mexico but
they do it kind of shady in this
situation because what they'll do is
they'll have a crew of people like 15 20
people and they'll have one guy who kind
of is ring leadering for them and he
necessarily doesn't speak very good
English because he's from Mexico too and
I'm the person who's got to help make
sure everything's good I love my job I
love my position there I learned how to
speak Spanish in the time I've worked
they're not fluently to where I can say
I speak Spanish but I can communicate to
people to where I can get the job done
we can communicate and you know
understand each other and I love that
part of my job but the disrespect on the
other on the other end before you get
too deep into this what is the job what
is what are your quality control I'm
sorry my my highest role that I have
that I am I'm happy that I have right
now is quality control so basically like
for example the the company that I'm
Legit right now is three units each unit
has four Grow rooms each grow room has
1400 plans give or take so pretty much
Monday through Friday at the end of a
day I pretty much take like a big Santa
Claus bag which I have to be super
careful of I'm like holding it like it's
like glass fragile of all these pounded
out bags of small nugs big nugs micro
nugs and I'm the one who has to take it
from the contractors who have been
working on it all day trimming it and
take it to the the distribution
downstairs I'm like the window the the
fence so to speak to take the product
say okay it's done now we can take it
from you you get paid and by the way
it's kind of crazy how to get paid man
so I'm not gonna lie uh I'm like around
20 an hour let's say that's exactly I'm
supposed to say that you know it's
whatever but they're getting paid these
contractors and I'm not gonna hate them
for it because I'm not doing it for I'm
not paying them paying them out of my
pocket but they're getting paid 80 to
100 per pound
now that's not per hour but a lot of
these guys are trimming in less than
eight hours six pounds
so if they're making you know like and
this is all cash they're not getting tax
for it they have legal rights to work
here because in Mexico some places where
there's like a lot of activity they're
able to get these uh visas or something
where they um where they can come over
for like six months at a time and work
here and it's legit they're insured by
the companies they work for so if
anything happens
they have money to Fork over for these
people and they're not citizens but
they're protected the their security
guards all over these places everyone
gets their IDs checked when they come
through the gate their green cards or
whatever paperwork they have you know
um but it's crazy how they get paid so
much money and I'm thinking in my head
like why couldn't as you know California
it's legal why can we figure out a way
to train just just citizens to do that
kind of stuff but that's another story
uh so even though it's been legalized
here in the states or in a lot of States
it's it's it's it's it's still like
shady to put it like and like I've so
back back up 20 years ago I've been
arrested plenty of times for having
small bags of weed on me for having a
small amount of weed for personal use
fast forward now like let's say six
months ago for example I was going
downstairs with one of those bags and
these bags when I say I'm going
downstairs with these this 50 pounds of
flour I really have to go through like
walking like walking through like people
have to get the [__] out of my way
excuse my language because everyone's
doing something to grow there but here I
am walking with the product this is the
money get the [__] out of the way and
anytime you bump into it or hits a wall
we're losing money because it's going to
degrade the product that's just the way
that we think about it you know it's
Gotta as fast as we can from flower
plant to the to the buyer which by the
way a lot of these distribution places
like if you have money for it you can go
to Adelanto and actually find out where
to buy pounds and stuff like that
legally because if you have the money
for it you can go to the actual
dispensaries and buy it there that's if
you have the money for it if you're like
Regular Joe Schmo like me you know we go
to the dispensaries and we get ripped
off because we're buying the stuff that
they're pushing as the top shelf high
quality stuff and it's really not that
great
as far as the quality and saying it's
not that great I don't mean to bash it
we have a lot of good quality weed
coming out in the Southern California we
got 35 percent coming out in some places
that's strong I'm like thinking in my
head like man I was a kid it was like 15
you know 20ish like at this point like
what 20 years from now it's going to be
like weed's gonna be a crystal or like a
mushroom or something it's not going to
be like green weed anymore but the fact
of the matter is weeds changing to where
we sell product to people that's not
that great and we push it as great and
it's like if it's legal and it should be
so open to everyone it should be easily
and readily available to get there's
issues to where like in the grows like
in these cultivation places indoor
growing like we have doing California in
the states nowadays since it's been
legal it's a newer thing it's like what
like coming on the second decade well
things that we've had to deal with that
have changed over time is there's always
these aphids that can sometimes get into
weed sometimes these aphids they're like
microscopic they can actually somehow
get insects yeah in the seed and the
seed can be you know have the insects on
them and somehow like they when the seed
grows they come out with it and they
just destroy the plants and destroy the
room well what happens is these aphids
have actually evolved so there's a new
there's a guy I forget the name of the
guy who did it but in Colorado he did
the study where he found this new Gene
this new hybrid or whatever aphid that
it grew to be indoors and it's just so
strong to it's hard to kill they've
tried so many things one time we had
this one issue where there's so many
aphids on some plants that were so good
that there was some small amount of
plants that were kind of like getting
the bugs onto other plants they actually
ordered like
I don't know how many thousands of
ladybugs I come into work I'm just like
why is this room full of ladybugs right
now they're like we're trying to get rid
of bugs I'm like okay someone must have
been eating some mushrooms yesterday
when they're trying to problem solve
right now and come to find out I'm like
what do you can do about the ladybugs
because it works but then you know
there's poop from the ladybugs I'm
thinking that's kind of gross I guess
that adds to the weed but they go well
we'll just get
um mantises I think oh cool so what do
you get to kill the Mantis a lion you
know it's like that cartoon where they
get something else to get rid of the
pests until you get something that's so
big so like all around all these Grow
Ups uh in Atlanta there's all these
matches everywhere because they've
bought so many mantises trying to just
kill off things cleanly that it's just a
funny thing about that and it's what's
gross is I've been in rooms where the
bugs are so thick that you just feel
like that you're getting bit sometimes
by being around the plants and it's just
like
ah I'm gonna smoke this one day huh and
uh there's things where I've been told
hey Steve this is a good trick when we
have these issues what we'll do is we'll
get the T-Rex tape that that industrial
size uh duct tape that's like you put it
on the wall and it comes off and there's
glue still or take off paint wherever
you put it I have to line the walls the
doorways like this thick I'm talking
like beyond the door the door's like
that it's got a seal because all those
doors are sealed for the plants and
stuff I got to make it like that much
further out because these these
microscopic bugs will just like March
their way out next day I come back and
it's just like thick you just see all
this it's like tidal wave all these dead
bugs I'm like oh that's disgusting and
I'm I'm not trying to scare No One by
saying that but you know when you're
smoking weed sometimes and you're like
man was that a seed because you're
smoking in your little pop it might not
be a seed it could be a bug it could be
the shell of a bug to pop but um
so you know with that being said with
the whole splitting of the people will
buy this and we'll have this and then
they have this Monopoly over people are
making so much money off of marijuana
and they really shouldn't it's marijuana
it should be you know easily and readily
available like we would think it is to
be legal
um but uh as far as like even going to a
dispensary there's places called seshes
in California I don't know if you guys
have heard of seshes this is I'm sure
some people are like yeah okay so you
know what I'm talking about sesh is
where you go to and it's a sesh like a
session you go to a brick and mortar
shop
but it doesn't say a dispensary outside
it doesn't have the nice fancy glass and
all those green crosses on it nothing
actually most time the tire shops or
something it's going to be a little
piece of [__] looking excuse my language
tire shop and it's going to say you know
whatever is kind of a big black gate
with tarps all around it and you go in
the back to security wind you down check
you you go in and it's just like a swap
meet of weed there's jars of mushrooms
everywhere I mean mushrooms aren't even
legal yet people are micro dosing and
that's another thing but
um the mushrooms the weed it's all there
and it's cheap I mean I'm gonna upset
some people right now with some prices
like like wax for example ounce of wax
like 30 grams I can get for like 60 70
bucks an ounce of weed you can get like
top shelf high quality that stuff that's
gassy that's like really strong you can
tell when you open it up it smells like
a fart like a chip bag that stuff you
can get for like 100 an ounce and by
saying that people are probably thinking
where am I going for this and I'm sorry
I can't tell you that but that's just
part of the industry it's like you have
to you have to go out there you have to
put your feelers out to like almost like
you're in the drug world when you're
just trying to buy weed you know a
regular person who works a normal job
it's legal I want to go buy some weed
what are you gonna do you're gonna go to
The Dispensary you're gonna buy this
[__] that excuse my language again that
we're telling you to buy because we want
to make the money we want to rip
everybody off as much as we can and you
know at the end of the day we're making
the most money and a lot of these places
the way I stay shady is it's because
there's not really like this like
this urge to be here 10 years from now
they're not probably gonna be here one
year from now the owners are probably
going to sell in California I'm sure
it's all over the United States I'm
pretty sure I've seen the sales for
these kind of places but they'll sell
the whole the whole expense the whole
I'm sorry the whole cultivation
when I work working there I'll have
people come by hey someone's coming by
and I'll make sure everything's clean
like okay it's the buyer they're trying
to have a buyer come in and they're
trying to see if they want to bid or buy
the place and it's like well I feel
great you know knowing that like every
every other day you guys are bringing
buyers in trying to like show me off as
you know someone worth buying or
something and this is my job so I feed
my kids and family
and I'm trying to like you know
normalize it to where it's a job I'm
going to work every day I'm trying my
best I come from a background of
customer service working in a customer
service field where I supervise people
so it's not a hard big deal for me to
watch people and help them get the job
done but I feel like it's an industry
where there's no heart there's no soul
and it's like this is weed like most
people would believe that this is like
like you know Heart and Soul 100 like
this is like weed people love weed I'm
I'm probably sound like weird even
saying that because growing up as a kid
smoking weed I remember scraping my
little glass pipes for resin that little
black tar [__] and when I don't have
stuff I would smoke that back in the day
kids nowadays they just go to The
Dispensary or call a delivery service
and they get it to the front door you
know it's it I'm not not bashing it I'm
just saying it is what it is and you
guys got to be careful if I can give
some like word of advice be careful what
you get a lot of weed can be dirty as
far as they'll use chemicals
to enhance things
um try to get like terpenes to come out
more stronger to make it more earthy to
give it more of that like oily type
heavier weed and what will happen is
sometimes they don't flush them
correctly like there's there's actual
like flushing processes for weed
depending what you do to it so let's say
um because most plants by the way have
mold by the end of it by the time we cut
that that plant there's mold already
growing in the brick that it's growing
from there's no matter what there's mold
and stuff tied to wheat all the time so
it's not as natural and clean as
everyone wants to say it is but when
wheat is
um when the wheat is broken down and and
transferred to be turned into oil for a
pan because people may want to only
smoke pens because it's they don't want
to roll joints or smoke a pipe they just
want to smoke pens be careful when you
go to places make sure you go in a
reputable place because a lot of these
guys they'll cut it and they'll just put
glycerin and stuff in there and refill
the cartridges and stuff and I just I
feel bad for people who are smoking
stuff that isn't what they're thinking
they're smoking and if that's just one
thing I would like to get process just
be careful where'd you get your stuff
from because back in the day before weed
was legal in some ways it was better
than it is now
that's a really crazy thing to even say
like even thinking about that is crazy
to think that weed was better when it
was illegal and it's only because the
quality and like the the the community
back then even as a youngster it's like
people were more of like well it's just
weed I'm gonna help you out this is weed
you know this nowadays it's like yeah
it's weed this is what it is buy it blah
blah it's it's turned it's almost like
weed is turned more evil in a way like
more darker even though it's legal it's
like
you know people don't all drink alcohol
but there's that there's not that evil
aspect of alcohol I feel like there's
evil to weed like people who are still
like grandparents and stuff and older
parents they might not want their kids
to smoke weed just because of this and I
wouldn't blame him if my son wanted to
you know take me to a dispensary and I
saw some of like the way they run stuff
nowadays like it's just not it's not as
easy going and free as you would think
and it
um as far as like even working with a
lot of these people and a lot of these
dispensaries I've learned that
um the drug world the drug war is only I
feel going to get worse at this point
the way they're going with it because
what they're doing is they created it to
where now the black market and selling
on your own is more of a thing now it's
like someone like me for example what
would stop someone like me from going to
the sesh and buying a quarter pound for
300 and then being the neighborhood drug
dealer for weed I'm not saying I do that
I don't because you know like I said I
work hard I do everything for my family
legit as best as I can but I like to
think on both sides of spectrum I think
for the underdog and it's like
it's not it's not as clean innocent as
people would think and I kind of wish it
was but uh that's kind of one of the
lights I wanted to shine on it I've
worked in dispense cultivations where
they literally like I go in there with a
couple people and it's just dark in
there they got lights turned off there's
you hear all these fans going on all
these generators and stuff backup stuff
turning on all water systems for
filtering water and stuff and it's just
like
it it's like wow this is so great but in
a way it could be better it could be
better and I feel like all of the the
industry is doing is milking to make
that money and as a pothead as a someone
who's like proactive for the uh for the
the against the drug War uh I think that
there's a lot of things we can do to
change make things better and you know
what's Shady too like talking about the
Shady thing I don't know if I I might
have like went over talking about it
earlier but when I talked about having a
smaller about amount of weed and going
to jail for it in the past when I was
younger there was that one day when I
went down the the stairway this one
building it was two three tiers high and
I was bringing down this big huge bag of
weed 50 60 pounds and I was I'm able to
carry it no problem I'm gentle with it
but as I'm going down the stairs there's
four sheriffs coming up
San Bernardino sheriffs and you know I'm
I'm not that I'm not a
I'm not pro or against police it is what
it is but I've been bullied a lot by
them so I have my own opinions
um so going down the stairway I like I
had I was going I had a happy I had a
good mindset the day's almost over it's
Friday I'm going home all of a sudden
the sheriffs are coming up and I'm at
work and all of a sudden I had this like
feeling inside sick like man what the
hell are they doing here like this is
legal like I'm doing my job we're doing
it why are they even here and they're
all smiling how's it going you're
nodding I mean I'm like what the hell
are they like nodding like we're buddies
or something for like this is weird and
then it's funny because as I'm coming
back upstairs from distribution to drop
off the stuff to sign off all the weight
make sure that it's all good I can
disconnect from it and go my other way
to the other building I see those same
sheriffs coming downstairs and their
grin is bigger and they got goodie bags
they got goodie bags from the weed place
and it's like
I don't know I'm not I'm not trying to
say anything good or bad about that but
it's really shady it's really shady that
feeling I got yeah I mean you know and I
get pulled over sometimes driving home
because they know around their the weed
build like I said who's driving around
there police security people working the
weed weed stuff and you can usually they
usually try to like um
they'll try to tell like oh that looks
like a car from someone who's coming
from the weed place or let's bug him and
I get bugged all the time it's like dude
I reek of marijuana I come home my wife
has to clean my clothes with like white
vinegar to like to get the weed smell
out or else it just bombs the laundry
and she wouldn't want that to happen but
uh
I love I love how where we're going as
far as the weeds getting stronger like I
said the 35 that's some strong weed man
when we when I was a kid like there was
and and you know I said I was joking
around saying like Weedle turn to a
mushroom one day if you actually look on
a weed like weed really close on a
microscope and you're looking at the
trichomes and the crystals they actually
before they actually get passed on to
bag to bag because when you get the weed
when you buy the weed yeah it looks like
gas looks like fire right like you're
you can't wait to go home and smoke it
that weed's been passed through so many
hands so many bags and it's so sad too
because I'll see really great weed like
we had this one strain new called Flamin
Hot usually at any building we have
eight designated strains growing at any
time that we know are gonna grow and
then we have four
play ones we're playing with they just
came out with one called Flamin Hot
Cheetos and I'm thinking in my head like
you can come up with a better name than
that but it looked in a way kind of like
you could see flaming hot Cheetos and it
had a little spicy taste to it and I'm
thinking man the weed is so great if you
look at the weed really close those
crystals look like mushrooms and it's
funny because when the weed's not being
passed through so many hands and stuff
you see the crystals and they look like
little mushrooms all the crystals and my
buddy was saying yeah like that's why I
joke around saying it's like mushrooms
one day all the weed will just be like
one big fungus mushroom and I'm like oh
that makes sense that's weird a little
something to think about it's kind of
crazy
um
the the strains are really good the new
stuff the the new like I said the new
genetics are pretty crazy most people
get the same seeds from the same place
like seed junkies seed junkies is a
place you can buy seats anyone can buy
seats from the um you can buy them uh
clones you buy clones from them uh
usually in our process we would have uh
eight to nine weeks it would take from a
plant to be
beginning to end now we do grow from
seed we do have our own genetics that we
play with like I said but we also have
to have stuff that just grows we have to
have stuff that grows that we can cut we
have like three tier highs these nice
state-of-the-art shelves that just move
aside and make it to where we can go up
on rafters and you know D leaf and stuff
and it's just like a jungle in there
it's so thick you wouldn't even believe
it because you figure these rooms are so
tall up and they literally use every
square inch of space for plants it's
really cool
um but uh it's you know all these all
these new strains and stuff that they're
coming out with everything's changing to
the point where where where everyone's
getting the same kind of stuff from the
same people but you have to be careful
what you're getting because like I said
some like Oreos for example Oreos is a
very big popular strain in Southern
California in Oregon I think horchata
right now is the big one but down here
is Oreos the Oreo strain is popping up
everywhere I've been to seshes down in
um there's some sessions down in a skid
row so if anyone's interested and
there's some in San Bernardino you
probably have to Word of Mouth go online
and start asking around and talk to
people but you go to these seshes and
it's like you see the same weed and it's
crazy because I've literally like gone
to LA to go buy weed after work and it's
like the same weed that like I was
working on at work I'm seeing down here
and I'm thinking like it's not the same
like coming from the same plants but
it's the same like seeds probably the
same clones
um we clone uh we clone most of our
plants
um Sometimes some of our plants don't
grow all the way there's issues where
people will forget to turn on the water
at the end of the day when someone
forgets to turn on the water at the end
of the day someone's getting fired I'm
sure if this was a black market grow or
something someone would get shot or beat
up but I've seen people get thrown out
pretty harshly over something that you
would imagine is innocent mistake but
when it comes to not turning on the
water at the end of the day that could
be a thirty thousand dollar mistake and
you can't do that you know there's
there's people who uh who aren't okay
with that
yeah I mean there's a lot to say about
it I mean there's a lot of there's a lot
of fun too so
um before quality control the thing that
got me to get to where I was at is on
the street I used to when I was a kid I
used to slang slang marijuana because it
was easy for me to grab a bag and split
it up and make the money back and just
rinse and repeat and I always had the
big OHA scale the big huge one where I
can scale like big weights ounces and
stuff and I'm really good at bagging and
being gentle with the weed I actually
have a skill of that I actually like
I've been there eight hour days where I
literally don't take my 10 minute break
because I know they're watching on
camera and I take my lunch but I
literally want to show them the machine
that I can be I can literally have my
tables going on with my scales and all
my bags and I set up everything before
the day starts and they're all trimming
get everything ready I get all my bags
ready and stuff I I impress myself I
showed I showed Mark I showed you some
of the pictures those pictures were all
on the table like that that's me that's
me just that's one room and I do that
times three in a day and I take pictures
of those because I'm like dang that
looks good like that's not my weed but
I'm the one who bags it prepared it like
that made look good because the bag
appeal is what you know sells and most
people buying the dispenser you see in
the little bags the holographic baggie
that makes you want to buy it because it
looks fancy but when in these
distributions and the cultivations we
sell them in those turkey bags where I
wrap that turkey bag and at the bottom
it's got the it's got the label that has
the um
the the labeling for the strain it is
the date and everything because people
come in by the pound pounds is the way
we want to sell it
pricing for pounds right now is around
fifteen hundred dollars
from the dispensary fifteen hundred
sixteen hundred dollars
um it used to before coven we were
getting like two grand 2500 for some of
them because there's like we're on the
way adelanto's on the way if you're
going to LA to Vegas it's halfway so
like if you're like a celebrity a rapper
which we have people like that come in
they like hey we need a pound for on the
road right now and they'll come in and
they'll buy a pound and they'll come
back hey we need more of that and we'll
sell sometimes we'll take them into the
room I'll take them to the room
one time one of Snoop Dogg's guys came
in before like legit like they came in
and the guy said hey these guys have
lots of money don't worry about your
normal job right now just sell sell weed
and so I'm like what are you guys
looking for so I'm like taking these
guys into the Grow rooms take letting
them squeeze it's funny I love doing
that too because you know when weed is
still growing in a way you can go up to
the plant you can take the nug you can
squeeze it and you can see like the
juices come out of it like you're
squeezing a lemon or something and
people like oh don't do that it's like
well you know I'm trying to show you
what's here now taking a nug not ripping
in half but I'll rip it just rip it open
a little bit so you can see inside there
look there's no mold nothing to look for
guys when you get really big nugs make
sure you're done gripped off and check
the inside so it make sure there's no
pink or peach in there because the mold
is very rampant nowadays but I would
sell so much money sometimes that that's
what got me into that position they're
like well you know what you're doing
with the weed like and in my head I'm
thinking well you guys don't because
most people who work there I'm gonna
throw them under the bus and a lot of
these people I'm sorry it just is what
it is you guys don't come from
cultivation backgrounds you come from
money to where someone dropped the money
and you run it and now you're hoping
that these group of people will run it
for you and you know I'm not going to
hurt not gonna
it is what it is you know I'm running it
for you but it's sad sometimes when
people will tell you something and they
don't know what they're talking about
it's like you have no idea what you're
talking about now and you're trying to
like push weed to where you're going to
have less less yield like different
strains different weeds will grow
different yields depending on the the
air airflow you have to have good proper
airflow you have to have the proper type
of lighting different type of plants one
different type of Lights
everyone thinks oh you just need the red
blue white red blue white it's like no
no you have to know your plants I matter
of fact knowing plants so well I know
one girl who she used to like talk to
mothers every day oh we have mother
rooms too which are great mother rooms
are the best place if you can ever go to
one of these places as a tour check out
the mother room because
you go in there's like 10 foot tall
plants and they're just like flourishing
and in a way like they seem alive like I
I totally have this new this I had one
day I was there and I was kind of
tripping out thinking about like man we
really torture these these women these
these mother plants because they're
sitting here vegging we tricked them
into thinking that they need to
pollinate so they can you know pass
seeds along do what they got to do
but all we're doing is we're sexually
frustrating them to get the biggest buds
out of them
or plants four plants but that's how you
do it man and uh
you know nowadays I'm learning I used to
always think the bigger nugs the better
it's such a science man every every
strain is so much different like I
remember when 9 11 happened right after
uh when I was a kid there was an influx
in Orange County for Afghan seeds I'm
like are you serious like like yeah
people are bringing over Afghan seeds
because apparently in the Middle East a
lot of them cultivate marijuana and
smoke a lot of marijuana over there so
you know there's a lot of army guys
Marines will go in there and
people run out and there's all these
seeds and stuff there so they'd send
them home well we had a lot of I
remember that that was pretty cool
there's always strains that are gone
like people listening you probably
remember strains like headband white
widow
um a lot of the older strains like that
like Jack Herer like they're all like
they're they're out there because seeds
last and people still have genetics but
man it's like it's so changed nowadays
it's it's they're all gone like a lot of
these strains are just not there and I
sometimes worry that like is the weed
we're smoking today giving us the same
kind of high like is there too much THC
in it now I'm going on a tangent that's
probably nuts that nobody wants to
listen to because we want to get as high
as we want as we can
um but you know that's where the weed's
going it's like I only wonder I really
wonder at the end of the genetic like
mutation that we're doing with the weed
what percentage THC it's going to be at
and will it even be legal at that point
because if the weed gets so strong it's
where you act like like you're gonna
fall over when you take a hit it might
not be legal no more haha so my only
question is how's your friend your good
friend Merle oh Merle's good Merle's
good you had an accident yeah he got in
an accident motorcycle shortly after
bike accident shortly after the last
interview I did with him it's crazy he
was on his way home and he actually was
on his way home he was in a parking lot
that's pretty open it was like early in
the day so no there's no even no one
parking there even there's just people
running jogging through it and some lady
just did not pay attention to the stop
sign like in front of her it's a stop
sign in the parking lot she figured was
nobody there I'm just gonna blow through
it and she hit him and she hit him so
hard though when he came to there was
police and paramedics around him and he
didn't know what the hell was going on
and Merle is a pretty like level-headed
guy he knows what's going on around him
at any given time and uh she knocked the
[__] out of him off that bike and you
know what's crazy is it's messed up I
don't mean to talk bad about police or
nothing but the whole time there was
there was witnesses there who stayed who
kept saying that it was her fault she
literally did not stop and she hit him
and the police the whole time were
trying to word it in the paperwork that
it was Myrtle's fault
and and Merle's like Delirious like
bleeding on the floor and these people
are like no no no this one guy was
really pissed off because he goes you
can't mess with that guy because he
looks like that like the Marietta police
like trying to like Bully some guy
because you know he's tattooed and looks
like that like oh this old lady must
have been right because she's you know a
normal looking person it must have been
this crazy looking [__] and so
but he's okay he had he has fluid a
little fluid in his head and it's uh
it's it's doing its thing I guess the
fluid builds up they had to postpone the
tour yeah he there's actually a couple
things that we were going to do recently
we were going to go to like the mentors
punk rock band they were gonna have the
Fourth of July party at their house and
we were gonna go hang out there they
call it rape Rock mountains but we're
gonna go there and hang out and uh he's
I told him I said Merle's not worth it
man because he's like you're right
because it's like that fluid it's like
whatever that thing is because you get
fluid in your knees and in joints and
I'm sure the body does that for a reason
it's no point in jarring himself anymore
at this point he needs to take it easy
but he's doing good tell him I said hi
yeah I will no you actually appeared in
the very first interview I did with
Merle and you together oh yeah uh when
you guys talked about your the serial
killer writers the serial killer you
know what's funny I don't know if I can
if you mind me talking about it right
now I actually made a lot of money since
that that interview because people have
been hitting up Merle and I want to sell
it like I want to sell this stuff like I
like holding on to it it's cool but if I
could sell it and I feel like what
better of a person's helped me sell it
than Merle like I never even thought in
my head that I'd oh Merle can you sell
this for me but like now because he's
home and he's got time in his hands when
the unit Obama passed away kazinski
remember since the last time we talked
he had died and the minute he died I'm
like well I'ma throw some stuff on the
internet just see the inner interest
people are messaging me tire kicking how
much do you want this 600 700's like you
know what I'm just gonna give it to
Merlin have him sell it he sold it he's
been selling things for thousand dollars
thousand thousand thousand it's like oh
my god dude like
it it I knew that one day it would be a
little monetary gain I I have a little
fear though like what if like 20 years
from now they're gonna be like triple
that invaluable you know it is what it
is it's helping me right now a little
monetary gain take the kids to
Disneyland and Knott's Berry Farm with
it
all right Steve well thank you so much
for uh enlightening my audience about uh
the weed industry yeah and uh I wish you
lots of Life yep thank you thanks